this is my brain somewhere under there
anyway this Hedgehog come and shower cap
is covered in electrodes carefully
pushed through with some conducting gel
onto my scalp all this so I can fly this
plane
a real life up in the air not a
simulator plane today my brain and the
plane are going to be interfaced I'm
going to fly by thought alone without a
pilot's license or frankly any
experience all it takes is really just a
tiny amount of practice in a simulator
I'm gonna be only the second person to
ever do this after the inventor santosh
that he's hoping that what he learns can
be used to improve human cognitive
capacity so this airplane here is the
King Air c90
it's a turbine powered airplane that we
use as a testbed for a lot of our
avionics testing but today we're going
to be doing a test for the brain
computer interface plugged into the air
airplane it sounds crazy to control the
plane I thought alone and to be honest
my main thought right now is just wild
terror I feel really sorry for the other
people on board in front of me is a grid
with a series of commands so all I'm
doing is just focusing on this screen at
the moment the green box is around the
descent ever I've got a climb and
brightness of all planes in the middle
and it have to focus really hard to
concentrate on one of those coming up at
the plane bopping by minute to turn
right I focus on the right arrow every
time it flashes my brain also flashes
with a kind of recognition pattern
that's recognized by the sensors and the
computer that they're connected to when
it's seen that aha pattern matching the
timing of one of the commands the
computer figures that that is what I
want to happen to help me focus on the
right thing Santosh suggests counting
every time I see a flash all right Jack
you're flying we spend the next 30
minutes going through some maneuvers
until I'm completely convinced that
system works by that time the pressure
both mental and just the physical
pressure of the cap on my head are
giving me a bit of a headache but I'm
prompted the pilot offers up a more
extreme test the collision path of n Chi
I can see defeat on this one but to be
fair this was a far bigger challenge
than the system or I were really
designed for in more regular calm flying
and I managed to trigger the correct
command about 90% of the time this isn't
going to replace the yoke and the pedals
anytime soon it's a proof of concept but
it's a thrilling one I still have
adrenaline pumping when the companies
land but I mean really who'd want to
have this thing stuck on your head just
to issue commands what we're doing in
our lab is to develop technologies to be
able to measure pilot workload attention
a whole bunch of parameters that affect
pilot performance in the flight day the
eventual goal is to get all this
technology working in real time in an
airplane but in order to do that we have
to be testing things in the actual
environment where the work so while we
don't envision an aircraft be controlled
by us signals for a long time we hope
that the work we're doing will help
create more robust technologies so you
may not get to ride on a
thought-controlled plane anytime soon
but technology is coming to make sure
your pilot is operating at peak
performance and that will make flying
safer for us all and don't worry I won't
be the one in the cockpit